watching American Horror Story is scary
enough but how does a cast feel as they
bring these stories to life
AHS seems to make a permanent impact on
it stars sometimes for the better and
sometimes for the worst here's how the
show has changed these actors lives in
the early years Evan Peters was
basically the face of American Horror
Story
he started out playing Tate Langdon in
the first season and went on to star in
seven more seasons of the creeped-out
anthology show it seemed like pizzas
would always be in the cast but that
didn't turn out to be the case in 2019
Pizza shocked fans to the announcement
that he wouldn't be returning for 1984
the ninth season of AHS and making our
choices every day honestly he probably
didn't miss out on much I just needed to
get each one of you along with me
why
so I can kill you fire - Peters
announcements the actor revealed that
AHS was taking a toll on his mental
health telling GQ in 2018 I don't like
to yell and scream I actually hate it I
think it's disgusting and really awful
for a story sort of demanded that of me
he went on to explain it's just
exhausting it's really mentally draining
and you don't want to go to those places
ever in your life and so you have to go
there for the scenes and it ends up
integrating it somehow into your life
Jessica Lange began her stint on
American Horror Story in season 1 or
Train Constance London Tate's malignant
mother the roller should in a whole new
phase of Lang's career winning her a
second Primetime Emmy she stuck with AHS
for three more seasons eventually
returning for apocalypse to reprise her
role as Constance honestly no one plays
an intimidating matriarch quite like her
Bundy downer
they started with small animals to tell
they graduated before getting that
career changing phone call from Ryan
Murphy Lange was going through a
difficult breakup she had just ended a
30-year relationship with actor and
playwright Sam Shepard and had no idea
what should do next in 2019 she told God
dhurbey going into that series somehow
revitalize me and made me understand
that there was a whole way of working
that I had never done before it forced
me to work in a way with complete and
total abandon the story checks out emma
roberts was tired of being typecast she
felt like casting directors only saw her
as a girl next door type so and wine
murphy offered her the role of powerful
witch Madison Montgomery she left at the
chance
we offer you our obedience and
everlasting devotion playing Madison
clearly gave Roberts a new sense of
confidence as she told Collider it's
definitely made me more of a fearless
actress things I would normally say no
sue I'm more like bring it on her stint
on AHS has certainly opened doors for
her too
in another interview with Collider she
noted I remember before Madison I would
go up to parts and they'd be like she's
too sweet or she's too nice now after
Madison no one says that it's easy to
see why I mean why wait for some phony
happily ever after when you can have
your piece now I say what about you look
Lady Gaga always wanted to break into
acting long before a music career ever
took off for proof look no further than
a bit roll on this Sopranos episode she
put those acting ambitions on the
backburner for a long time but why'd
Murphy ultimately help turn that dream
into reality he cast her as a vampiric
countess in American Horror Story hotel
I lived in New York many years ago I
loved roaming the streets devouring the
pulse of the city
electrifying as Murphy told Billboard in
2015 she has always wanted to be an
actress she studied it in college but
she was too terrified to go on auditions
when Murphy showed her footage of one of
her scenes in AHS Gaga reportedly began
to sub Murphy told Billboard I was
worried but she told me later that it
was because she was so happy that
somebody had believed in her Gaga's
newfound confidence as an actress
changed her entire career she went on to
star as Ally alongside Bradley Cooper in
the 2018 remake of a star is born which
was nominated for several Academy Awards
and won Best Original Song for shallow
American Horror Story freakshow wouldn't
have been complete without twisty the
clown the terrifying carousel was played
by actor John Carroll Lynch and there
was his first time ever working on the
show the character had a rather nasty
habit of sneaking up on people and
killing them and the fact that twisty
barely spoke a word made him all the
more frightening that proved to be quite
an actually challenge for Lynch who had
to rely solely on body language for the
performance as he told Collider in 2014
there are a lot of things I've never
tried before because a character is
silenced there was a challenge of being
told there's almost no
dialogue and we're gonna take away half
of your face let's see if you can act in
those circumstances judging by his
nightmare-inducing performance as twisty
would say he nailed it and became a more
versatile actor in the process in 2018
Cody Fern joined American Horror Story
for Apocalypse he memorably played
Michael Langdon otherwise known as the
Antichrist to prepare for the paths and
get into the mindset of a ghoulish
entity like Michael Byrne spent lots of
time reading up on theology psychology
and philosophy Michael has been Ferns
biggest role to dates and apparently
fern still hasn't entirely moved on from
the character in June 2019 he told gold
Derby people have more of an interest in
the darker aspects of life and I think
it's very much about trying to
understand the darkness within ourselves
I'm a serious actor check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the pal so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you